hello flash funny girl
and I'm going to remember it takes to
see me to meet you something getting
rather violent you're young age we need
to stay within his power source
definition if you don't use this iris is
going to die tonight I can't believe it
turn t-shirt into a guard deliver shock
that's a door
hey everybody its Charlie in the name of
the speedforce we need to pull a heist
so the trailer clears up a couple story
beads namely how captain cold comes back
if he's supposed to be dead in present
day it's really crazy with the timeline
so I'll explain the legends of tomorrow
captain cold timeline as of the end of
season two because they clean some
things up he's still around but there
are couple caveats to that and there is
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so even if you don't read comics
you probably remember they referenced
the name Infantino a lot in the air
overs Carmine Infantino is the person
who created pretty much every big blast
rogue that you've seen even the
reverse-flash himself so even though
it's a big argus Suicide Squad king
shark episode there's a lot of Carmine
Infantino stuff happening the person
that created the Suicide Squad was Jim
Australia so not quite the same person
but they do explain the king shark is
working for Argus as a guard dog for
this alien power source and it took me a
minute to remember because it's been a
while since I've seen the episode but I
was like wait when is the flash dealt
with aliens oh yeah during the big
crossover episode
is Express
[Music]
so that means that this is left over
from the dominators there are a lot of
aliens on Supergirl but that's just
because she's from outer space there's a
lot of interstellar villains on that TV
show
most of the villains from flash narrow
tend to be from earth but I love the way
that they're going to Argus on pretty
much every show Argus is also a big part
of the arrow puzzle the last couple of
episodes and Prometheus is planned for
Oliver but I'll talk about that during
my arrow video tonight but always get a
lot of questions about king shark
anytime there's a big character like
Grodd the big CG characters that are
really really big comic book characters
they always find a way to bring them
back it looks like they're successful
because he powers the weapon up in the
trailer it takes a shot at saboteur but
that feels like one of those last final
moments that pushes them into the finale
like they're not going to defeats avatar
and they just stand around for an hour
in the finale obviously there's going to
be some big twists we'll probably still
find ourselves in this moment here where
iris is getting ready to die with some
twist though I know a lot of people are
like okay what if HR is the person that
died he has that base changing
technology this what did you do you
should neutralize us no I can't do
simple retinal adjustments so all of you
can see me HR law the rest of the world
geez Randolph Park there are a number of
ways to explain how they can still be in
this moment here in iris can die without
the actual iris die captain cold though
which version of the character is he so
it looks like he picks him up outside
the Waverider so Barry has to travel to
some point in time this seems like it's
during season one of legends of tomorrow
when Captain Cold was still alive he
died at the end of season 1 but then
over the course of season 2 heat wave
started to hallucinate him but then the
reverse-flash pulled him out of time
into the present when he was still evil
brought him to present day but then they
fixed everything at the end of that
season took everybody back to where they
belong reset their memories so the last
point in time when Captain Cold is alive
now is right before season 1 of legends
of tomorrow
when he joins the team on the Waverider
so the only way to get captain colds
help now is to travel to some point
before he went on the Waverider like an
earlier version of the character or
traveled somewhere during the wave
riders timeline so it looks like that's
what Barry is doing he's just traveling
to somewhere during the season one
legends of tomorrow timeline grabbing
him and then he'll bring him back at the
end of the adventure totally love
Wentworth Miller it's all about Barry
doing bad things to try and achieve a
good end so Captain Cold is having a lot
of fun with this who Barry a heist this
is my kind of plan this is going to be
fun there was some more footage in the
other trailer that I posted so I'll link
that at the end of this but the big
thing now is wrapping up this avatar
plotline getting rid of him in a way
that will allow Barry to come back
during season four as well as sort of
solidifying what the new team flash is
going to look like I think we might lose
a char but will gain Traci brand so
killer frost is really like the other
big piece of that puzzle if you saw her
in the elevator where her eyes went back
to normal Caitlin dies that seems like
what she's going to look like during
season four danielle Panabaker the
actress said the only thing that's
really hard about doing killer frost is
wearing those blue contacts she said
that she can barely see when they're in
so it sounds like they're going to take
the contacts out so that it's much
easier for her to walk around and
interact with the other actors and do
her scenes so it's actually very doable
for her to wear that makeup all the time
through season 4 Julianne at the end of
the episode was a big part of that too
confessing his love for her so I think
they're trying to leave the door open to
Tom felt that if he wants to come back
for Season 4 we could get Julian but
typically people don't get really big
happy endings like this Barry kind of
gets a happy ending because I think that
iris is going to survive but they've
been really quiet about what's going on
with tom felton future on the show and
he hasn't said anything about whether or
not he's going to be doing another TV
show in the fall there is a movie that
he signed up to do but it's a relatively
small indie movie like Grant Gustin did
last year between seasons so I don't
think there's any scheduling conflicts
preventing him from doing season 4 of
the flash but you guys can let me know
do you think that tom Felton will come
back and play Julian in season 4 or do
you think they're going to write him off
the show the thing about arrow is they
did confirm they were going to kill
multiple characters and we only really
know about
one character on the flash that's
probably going to die but it could go
either way I think he's done a good job
this season it's been a relatively
interesting character but I'd like to
see some big plot line from him and
season four if they're going to bring
him back but part of the fun of the
flash isn't seeing multiple versions of
the characters like we've seen so many
different versions of Barrie because of
the Savitt art twist this year there's
always a crazy number of Harrison wells
the only real version of Cisco that I
haven't liked this season so far was the
really mopey version right after they
came back after flash point I feel like
Cisco the last couple of episodes like
the way he's acting
that's genuine Cisco that's the version
that you want you want them to have that
pain inside of him that tragedy because
it helps give his character a lot of
depth but you don't want the characters
to be super mopey and bummed out even
killer Frost was making fun of sabot r4
brooding too much brooding time is over
we need to become gods before he puts
her in the chokehold so there's a whole
bunch of stuff happening the next couple
of weeks on the DC TV shows as well as
the other superhero comic book shows so
what I'm going to do next is a really
big agents of shield Ghost Rider video
that I need to do to get everybody ready
for the finale
then there's new arrow I'll post the
episode video I have a bunch of new
spider-man these are basically the
videos that I'm working on for like the
next day and a half or so I'll try to
get through that stuff as fast as
possible but as long as you have alerts
enables you should be able to get
everything whenever it post so I'll try
to get through it as fast as possible so
just make sure you click that little
bell so you don't miss out but while you
wait for that click here for that brand
new flash footage and you can click here
for my flash episode from last night
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys tonight